Transcriber: Gizem D
Gözden geçirme: Rıza Özdemir
Herkese merhaba.
Sene 2013.
Yazılımcı bir arkadaşıma dedim ki
benim şöyle bir fikrim var.
Bunu yazar mısın?
Dedi ki, ya yazarız yazmasına ama
Türkiye’de tutmaz bu iş.
Üzerinden 4 yıl geçti.
Sene 2017, ilk yatırımcı görüşmelerimizi
yapıyoruz.
Hiç yatırım almadan 100 bin kullanıcın
üzerine çıkmışız.
Düzenli olarak büyümüşüz.
Görüştüğümüz yatırımcı dedi ki, ya Özden
Hanım, tamam güzel, çok düzenli birisiniz
ama Türkiye’de tutmaz bu iş.
Ben bugün buraya şimdi ya da hiç teması
altında girişimcilikten, özellikle de
kadın girişimciliğinden
söz etmek için geldim.
Peki sizce iyi bir fikri olup da
hayata geçirmeyenlerle o ilk adımı atanlar
arasındaki fark nedir, hiç düşündünüz mü?
Okulda, işte ya da dost sohbetlerinde
illaki şöyle konuşmalar geçmiştir.
Ya yemin ederim Yemeksepeti’nin
aynısını ben düşünmüştüm.
Ya da şöyle bir app yapsak
harika olmaz mı?
Ya da şöyle bir fikrim var.
Beraber yapalım mı?
Ne dersin?
Peki sizce güzel fikirleri olup da bunları
hayata geçirenlerin oranı nedir?
Aslında doğruyu söylemek gerekirse hemen
herkesin güzel etkileri vardır.
Ama girişimcilik fikrini cesaretle
hayata geçirendir.
Yani elini taşın altına koyandır.
Bu ister hızlı, ölçeklenebilir teknoloji
gelişimi olsun, isterse kendi yaptığı
ürünleri sattığı küçücük bir dükkan
olsun asla hiç fark etmez.
Senin içinde seni harekete geçirecek
cesaret ve güç var mı?
Asıl soru bu.
Peki sizce girişimcilik sadece cesaret ve
güçle mi ilgili? Mesela kadın ya da
erkek olmak fark eder mi?
Şunu kabul edelim ki maalesef hala çok
cinsiyetçi bir dünyada yaşıyoruz.
Bir kadın bir iş kurmak istediğinde biraz
önce dediğim gibi isterse çok hızlı
eklenecek bir koku şirket olsun ya
da ev yemekleri yapan küçücük bir
yer hiç fark etmez.
Önüne bir sürü bariyer çıkar.
Çok net görünen bariyerler ya da kurumsal
hayattaki gibi görünmeyen cam tavanlar ve
bunlarla mücadele etmesi gerekir.
Kadınlar finansmana ulaşmakta, ekip
kurmakta, çevreden ya da aileden destek
görmekte, daha da önemlisi
bir işe cesaretle cüret etmede hep
önlerinde bariyerler ile karşılaşırlar.
Özellikle bizim gibi coğrafyalarda.
Ve inanın bana o görünmeyen bariyerler
en az görünen bariyerler
kadar kadınları zorlar.
Peki ben nasıl yaptım?
Ben Özden Pusat ismim.
Öğretmen bir anne babanın
çocuğuyum ve öğretmenler içinde büyüdüm.
Çok iyi bir eğitim aldım.
Üniversiteden mezun olunca da hem o
dönemin koşulları gereği hem de güvenli
ve iyi bir iş tanımına uyduğu için
Türkiye'nin büyük bankalarından birinde
hem CEO olarak çalışmaya başladım ve sonra
15 yıl çeşitli bankalarda kurumsal
bankacılık yaparken kendime çok güzel
bir konfor alanı yarattım.
Bu nedir işte iyi bir maaş, araba,
yan haklar vesaire.
Ve ama bir yandan da ya gerçekten
yapmak istediğim bu mu?
Gerçekten mutlu musun?
diyen iç sesimi de sürekli
bastırdım. Şimdi
Z kuşağı ve sonraki kuşaklar için deniyor
ki gelecekte birbirinden farklı üç tane
kariyerleri olacak.
Ama bizim jenerasyonumuzda bize gösterilen
yol ve algımız öyle değildi.
Bir kurum değiştirebilirsin, benzer
sektörlerde bir işe girebilirsin.
Ama yıllarını verdiğin bir sektöre arkanı
dönüp bambaşka bir iş yapmaya kalkmak.
Baya bir maceraperest olarak
bakılıyordu.
Ben ama bu içimde yükselen, gerçekten
bu işi yapmak istiyor musun,
gerçekten mutlu musun diyen, sesi
daha fazla bastıramadım
ve kurumsal hayatı bıraktım.
2013 yılında sürdürülebilirliğin yeniden
kullanımın ikinci olup hiç ama hiç
konuşulmadığı bir ortamda Türkiye'nin ilk
kadın ve çocuk ürünlerine yönelik ikinci
olman pazar yeri olan tutumu haneye koydum
ve bu işi yapamazsın diyenlere de
kulaklarını tıkadım.
İlk olarak, ilk bu fikir aklıma geldimi
önce dünyada neler oluyor ona baktım.
Trendler nasıl?
Bu işin büyüme potansiyeli var mı ?
Dünyaya ve başkalarına fayda yaratırken
bir yandan da büyüme potansiyeli olan bir
iş kurabilir miydim?
Bu soruları sordum kendime.
Ve evet hiç unutmuyorum ilk aklıma geldimi
o kadar heyecanlanmıştım ki
sabaha kadar Google taraması yapmıştım.
Tabi ben bu kadar heyecanlandım ama şimdi
bu işi hayata geçirirken başkalarına.
İşte sürdürülebilirliğin önemini, ikinci
el almanın ve satmanın ne kadar mantıklı
olduğunu, dünyada kaynaklar hızla
tükendiğini anlatmam gerekiyordu.
Yani bunun hiç konuşulmadığı bir ortamda
ben kurduğum girişimle
bir davranış değişikliği yapmam
gerekiyordu.
Davranış değişikliği dediğiniz şey de
aslında bir nevi Don Kişot’luk.
Size şöyle bir hayali diyalogla
anlatmaya çalışayım.
Mesela ben diyorum ki: ya şu
ağaçları görüyor musun?
Ha ağaç mı ?
Evet, galiba var orada bir ağaç.
Üstündeki ayvaları görüyor musun?
Tam emin değilim.
Göremiyorum galiba.
Ya o ayvaları toplayıp onlardan
reçel yapsak?
Çok güzel olmaz mı?
Karşımdaki diyor ki, ya hiç
ayvadan reçel olur mu?
Aslında kullanıcı karşıdaki
ağaçları bile göremezken
siz girişimci olarak o ağaçlar üsteki
ayvaları görüp
onları toplayıp reçel
yapmayı hayal ediyorsunuz.
Yani aslında davranış değişikliği böyle
bir şey ama çok karamsar bir tablo
da çizmek istemem.
Yaptığımız işin gerçekten bir karşılığı
varsa siz de bir kaşif gibi deneyip
yanılarak, emek harcayarak çabaladığımız
zaman bunun karşılığını görmekte
gerçekten çok keyifli.
Biz ekip olarak en çok kendimize
şu soruyu sormuştuk.
Nasıl yapsak daha iyi anlatırız?
Mutlu kullanıcı deneyimleri mi anlatsak?
Sosyal medya daha efektif
ve kullansak ama nasıl?
Ara yüzü mü değiştirsek?
Kullanıcı testleri mi yapsak?
Sonuç olarak bunun hepsini ve
hatta daha fazlasını yaptık.
Çünkü denemek ve yanılmak asla bitmiyor.
Ama bütün bu çabaların sonucunda da mesela
sosyal medya takipçilerinizin ya
da kullanıcı sayıların, hızın ya da
satışlarınızın böyle tık tık tık
yükseldiğini görmekte,
yani verdiğiniz emeklerin karşı aldığınızı
görmekte inanılmaz keyifli.
Sonuç olarak tutumlu anne ilk başta sosyal
medya ve word of mouth dediğimiz kulaktan
kulağa duyumla, sonra da Türkiye’nin önde
gelen melek yatırımcılarının aldığı
yatırımlarla düzenli olarak büyüdü ve 500
bin kullanıcısı olan ayda 1.3 milyon
ziyaret alan bir platforma dönüştü.
Ama şimdi baktığımda aslında başından
sonuna kadar
bir Netflix dizisi gibi kan,
ter ve gözyaşı içeriyor benim hikayem.
Çünkü inişler, çıkışlar, başarılar,
ödüller, mücadele,
çalışma, çalışma, çalışma.
Hep bir mücadele halinde geçti.
Ama ben ilk başta kendime şunu sordum,
şunu düşündüm.
1- Neyi bilip bilmediğini farkına var.
2- Bilmediğin şeyi ya öğren ya
da bilen birini yanına al.
Bu bilen biri bir ekip üyesi olabilir,
bir mentor olabilir,
hatta bir yatırımcı olabilir.
Tabii ben kurumsal hayattan bir sürü
deneyim getirmiştim bu işi kurarken.
Ama benim, girişimciliğin bana kattığı en
önemli şey, yaşınız kaç olursa olsun her
şeyi öğrenebilirsinizi anlamak oldu.
Ve ben o süreçte gerçekten
çok fazla şey öğrendim.
Mesela teknolojiden pazarlamaya.
Onlar pazar yeri metriklerinden
devlet desteklerine bir
sürü şey öğrendim.
Mesela yatırımcılar ne bekler, sunum nasıl
hazırlanır, asansör sunumu nedir
bunları öğrendim.
Ya da yatırımcı hayır dediğinde,
bir kullanıcı ya da
başka biri sizi eleştirdiğinde
bunu kişiselleştirmemeyi öğrendim.
İşler planlandığı gibi gitmediğinde
pivot etmeyi ya da
mücadeleden vazgeçmemeyi.
Problemler çıktığında her şeyi tek başıma
çözmem gerekirdi, ziyade destek almam
gerekir demeyi bilmenin önemini
bu süreçte öğrendim.
Ama en önemlilerinden biri
kendimin güçlü ve zayıf
yanlarını öğrendim ve hayatın da
girişimciliğin de özünün aslında öğrenmek
hiç bir zaman bitmez olduğunu anladım.
Evet,
adım atmak lazım.
Yola çıkmak lazım
ama kervan yolda düzülür
deyip hiçbir hazırlık yapmadan
yola çıkmak ne kadar yanlışsa, yola çıkmak
için bütün koşulların mükemmel
olduğu anı beklemek de bir o kadar yanlış.
Çünkü öyle bir yol hiçbir zaman olmayacak.
Şimdi geriye dönüp baktığımda harekete
geçmek deyince şunu hatırlıyorum.
Site canlıya alınıncaya kadar iş fikrimi
bir sır gibi saklamıştım.
Ama şimdi buradan baktığımda
bana çok komik geliyor.
Çünkü aslında iş fikriniz dinlenme ama
teknoloji üretme olsanız iş fikrinizin
çok da bir önemi yok.
Siz o fikrinizi de harekete
geçiyor musunuz?
O iş fikrinize yol ver, inişleri
çıkışları karşı esnek misiniz?
Yeri geldiğinde yol değiştirebiliyorsunuz.
Önemli olan gerçekten bu.
Ayrıca girişiminiz devam etmeyebilir,
kapanabilir ama her girişimci mutlaka
öğrenir ve o oradan öğrenilen deneyimin
zenginliği ne okullarda ne de kurumsal
hayatta yoktur.
Bu arada girişimcilik demişken,
bunu sadece
bir iş kurmak gibi de bence algılamayın.
Bence harika sosyal girişimciler var.
Ya da çalıştığı kurumda
üstüne vazife olmadığı halde
yepyeni icatlar yapan.
Bir şeyi farklı yapmak konusunda
kurumunuza örnek harika kurum için
girişimciler var.
O yüzden girişimcilikle ilgili
genelde şöyle bir algı var.
Girişimcilik genelde hayal gücüdür
ve iyi fikirler bulmaktır diye.
Ama bana göre girişimciliğin %80′i
hareket etmek,
öğrenmek ve
yeniden denemektir.
Hareket et, öğren, yeniden dene.
Son bir cümlem vardı.
Şunu söyleyeceğim.
Bugünün teması şimdi ya da
hiçti.
Ben size bir soru
bırakarak buradan ayrılmak istiyorum.
Sizi harekete geçirecek şey nedir
bir şeyleri değiştirmek için?
Teşekkür ederim.